you've actually been tested twice I sent
in my secret diner and this is what you
saw here we are doing it I told the you
family to focus on detail and to
properly seasoned the stunning
ingredients they sauce and I want to see
them use the waiting staff wisely so
they're not just hanging around
I booked a table I got table David
Duncan for two people late o'clock
would have hoped you've been offered a
drink by now having been there by me I
know they're busy but it's quite a lot
of staff as well because he's managing
the place it all feels a bit frantic I
really would like to have a drink that
you can get rather night we're all some
drinks to call over the waitress to get
a drink that's giving it to my right
it's for waiters and waitresses they've
all got their backs to us I'm sure that
busy it's a busy night but
leeta ten minutes for a drink
is that normal they wait 10-15 minutes
no it's not
well that wasn't an um Friday night
because one of the kitchen hands was
I'll fail yeah
so I had to go in and the hell these
guys that's me I disappeared for so long
we need to do is pay money for better
staff and less of them that are more
reliable so our starters really really
which was the problem is there's now a
huge gap Aryan starters main fortress
they should bring the stage a little bit
later would be such a glaring gap
well they should be doing now is coming
up to us just having a quiet we're
saying you know what that would
completely dilute the situation
completely ignored completely ignored it
becomes an insult where they become
offended like you said diffuse it sorry
yeah that's okay okay thank you
this diverse all with sugar snap peas
carrots looks actually rather by the
plant and the fish itself
it's been on the script hi there I just
this Dover so doesn't you taste them
much and it's much more seasoning yeah
when you've got customers that are sat
waiting over half an hour your food it's
got to be perfect and I was dealt with
quite well so I'm gonna send this crap
again and asked to change
I'm so sorry after all that effort I
complain a lot that's the best I ever
seen that Darwin cannot obtain for
dealing with a very very tricky customer
brilliantly handled and he's fussing
beautifully done I really really really
really like that it's probably slow so
it's worth the trip alone seriously
I've never heard such an amazing
compliment to Chinese desserts
fantastic really good the dining
experience I'm going to sluggish start
but it's just accelerated and I've now
reached a crescendo where I think is one
of them
Chinese restaurant I've been to many
years what a strong finish and he left
on a high got this far now we just
really want to I'm ready to explode I'm
ready to win this competition I'm gonna
take this and hope get to the end of
this competition you know